welcome back to new rock star I'm Eric
Voss and are all the Netflix Marvel
titles now officially Canon to the MCU
616 secret timeline holy crap we just
got a big bombshell dropped by a Marvel
executive for the echo series the
marketing is in full swing we've gotten
comments from the head of streaming
television and animation Brad wibom
someone who's been with Marvel Studios
since the early days and also a new
promo that is coming out for the echo
series using footage from Wilson fisk's
time on the Daredevil series was made by
a completely different division of
Marvel entertainment and it's all down
part of the same canonical backstory
maybe we're going to explain how this
all makes sense how the the Netflix
series could fit into with the MC MCU or
have we been overthinking it do they
already fit in with the MCU this is a
huge day lot of a lot of stuff to talk
about this is a sneak peek where we're
taking a temperature of whatever we're
watching while we look ahead to the next
week in nerdom and Echo is on the
horizon and Echo is bringing with it a
lot of Echoes from the past of Netflix
Marvel en joining me to talk about this
is of course Jessica Clemens hi I'm here
I'm ready to be canon in the MCU as well
Kevin feige this is my message to you I
can't act but I see a lot of people in
the MCU that can't
act what name names Jessica no I would
never I would never
no stop I would never I would never I'm
now like thinking like who does she mean
I have my opinions on this I think we
have hear some
rituals okay but I'm excited there's so
much to talk about because this question
over whether or not Daredevil and all
the other Netflix Marvel shows whether
they're Canon to the MCU has been such a
feisty debate on social media it started
as like a wholesome campaign but now now
it's become one of these things where
like if you ever said or or said
anything in regards to this question you
would have half of Twitter yelling at
you and would like do everything in
their power to cancel you and would just
like harass you on every single one of
your posts like oh yeah well you're the
guy who says that like Daredevil was an
MCU Canon you [__] idiot and then I'd
be like what I was just quoting Charlie
Cox in a in a like in an interview he
did a Comic Con a couple years ago
that's on you you stupid stupid man I am
a stupid stupid man well now we finally
got some clarity from uh from Marvel
Studios executive Brad wibom and you got
to imagine even though he said I'm just
saying this on behalf of Brad wibom all
these executives are considered
mouthpieces for Kevin fe uh so I I think
that like we we'll play his clip but
this is a very big deal it's also comes
into a contradiction with like what was
just said in a Marvel timeline book
because none of that was like none of
the Netflix stuff was in that but there
was a little message from Kevin feige
where he's like hey other stuff is being
made by other Studios who knows what
might get retconed into MCU canonicity
wink wink and I think he was talking
about this he's talking about X-Men he's
talking about the sod spiderverse but
yeah he's also talking about the Netflix
universe so like we'll get an update to
that book maybe maybe or they'll just
throw in more um Mis minutes to be like
clearing it up for y'all clearing it
yeah I was reading it last night that's
why I'm trying to reach for it oh God my
back I was reading it last night and I
was looking at all of the things that
Miss minut did fix in here and like all
their little blurbs and there's a lot so
they they might just do that she fixes a
lot okay let's catch everyone up on what
we're talking about here Brad wibom is
the head of streaming television and
animation at Marvel Studios he sat down
with Joe deom Meer over at Screen Rant
and he had this to say now I have a
question about Daredevil is everything
that happened on the Netflix series a
part of the Sacred timeline or is it not
so I can say that we've been we've been
up until this point we've been a little
bit Cy about what's sacred timeline
what's not sacred timeline that was that
was born of frankly a period at the
studio where we were like we have to
stick the landing with Avengers sure you
know we it was it was another part of
the company developing the Netflix stuff
we were aware of what they were doing
they were aware of what we were doing
but it it was it was a it was it was a
lot it was a lot to balance anyway but
now that you know some time has passed
now that we see how actually how well
integrated the stories are um I think
that I personally Brad WBAL would be
confident in saying it is part of the
Sacred time wow so additionally during
the week Marvel's marketing team put out
a new trailer featuring shots of Kingpin
using footage from the Netflix shows and
all this has us pretty convinced that
Marvel has finally answered the question
of whether or not those shows should be
considered Canon now we should be clear
though wi bomb is just saying like uh it
inspired us while we were making this
show an Ekko and Daredevil that like we
wanted to like maintain probably the
spirit of it but how far do you think
they're GNA go Jess oh my gosh I hope
they go um I get what they're saying I
get what they're saying and this is this
is a
different well I'm like it is a
different it's not the you you can't
recreate Marvel's Netflix um and they're
not trying to replicate Marvel's Netflix
they kind of just want to bring in a
little bit of it and like imagine a
strainer of Daredevil and they take all
those little bits and put it in there
and I get that it's it's I I every word
I'm gonna say sounds very offensive I'm
trying to make it not uh I don't think
they're they're not gonna make a water
down version of the Marvel or Netflix's
Daredevil but they're trying to take
piece the good pieces of it and I
understand that I understand doing that
it's an amazing show all of them were
amazing yes I think what he is saying is
that like in terms of what has brought
Matt Murdoch to the point he is at right
now and everything that's brought Wilson
Fisk to where he is at right now this is
spiritually and
thematically part of the same language
and the same history and the same world
as what we saw on the Netflix Marvel
show but I don't think that means every
little thing that we saw on those shows
is going to be addressed and is going to
come back and and the current characters
and what they're currently going through
are going to be held to all of those
things I think really what's going to
happen is the longer these shows go on
remember Daredevil born again is 18
episodes there is going to be stuff that
comes up on these shows that will
directly contradict what like if you
hold those Netflix Marvel shows to be
gospel to be a sacred text you're G to
be disappointed I think you just have to
like just remember what was good about
those shows and what you liked about
those shows generally and not like go
back through them and look at the
transcript because I think you're just
setting yourself up to be disappointed
like it's hard enough to do that in the
MCU with their own titles I mean look
how hard it's been for Marvel to do that
since they started doing streaming shows
like things contradict or just
thematically and tonally contradict all
the time like the number of minutes of
screen time in the three seasons of
Daredevil like might be more than uh
phases one two and three of the MCU
right like which only had movies only
two-hour movies
like that's a lot of content a lot of
content that like you know Marvel
Studios would now have to be beholden to
yeah I don't think they're gonna take
it's it's hard I can't even give you a
good example right now I don't think
they're G to take like literally every
part like you said but taking that um
that Kingpin history is pretty you have
to um you can't you have to I kept
saying like there is no there's nothing
that Disney has said so far that makes
it clear that Kingpin did kill his
father and if they change that that
would be really weird for them to do so
I really hope they don't and now that
they put that into that little teaser I
was like okay thank God they like it is
still that history so those are like big
moments but I don't think like Bullseye
is that big of a moment I don't think
Electra is that big of a moment why are
you making that face do you think
they're going to bring alra no because
your cat loves alectra oh she she won
she doesn't get enough of that [__] and
I said cat you don't understand they
didn't do a good job uh but they did a
great job I just don't I didn't really
like Electra that much but I don't think
those are characters that are like so
big that they and made such a Chokehold
on Daredevil the series that they have
to show up but King's dead yeah what's
hard about it is they have recast
characters they it's we have a different
Vanessa now on the show um and so
there's going to have to be some things
that we just kind of let go of you need
a Vanessa but it's a different actor and
I think that's just gonna be confusing
to people who just try to watch every
episode of Daredevil seasons one two and
three are you gonna be be confused when
you see the new Vanessa and be like
should have been old Vanessa are you
rooting for old Vanessa no not at all
and I like the actress who they brought
in for new Vanessa I'm just saying like
statements like this where we viewed it
as Canon it's like well then why did why
did you recast some people not others
it's a different
person they're like we want a is it a
different person Nam Vanessa is it a
different Universe no I think what
they're saying is it's the same universe
and I think it's easier honestly at the
end of the day I'm in favor of just
adopting what we saw on the Netflix
shows because it was good and I think
this is a hard truth we have to admit
the Netflix series have had in general
ooh I think in general have had more you
said you said ooh what are you about to
say no say it don't think about it say
it go ahead say it okay um the Netflix
Marvel shows have had a better batting
average of quality well than Marvel
Disney plus is when you have only like
three not that three I will I'll
yeah I'm just saying there was a lot of
bad ones a lot of the Season twos of
those shows weren't that good but you
know you you had Daredevil season one
you had Punisher and you had Jessica
Jones season one and those were so good
those seasons were so freaking good and
then on Marvel Disney plus you've had
Loki season one and two which were
incredible you had ju Division I liked
Ms Marvel she had a couple good episodes
Haw Hawkeye was okay
but
like Netflix got a long a little bit of
a longer time right they got like two
three years two or three years it was
like 201 let's see they Daredevil
started in 2014 2015 and then they were
done by 2018 for that and think of the
ones that only got like one or two
seasons I'm thinking about the Jessica
Joneses but yeah maybe not bad and
average I shouldn't have said bad and
average because it's like they had a lot
of bad a lot of bad a lot of bad that
was worse than anything we've seen from
Marvel Disney Plus
but but when it was good it was yeah and
they don't have to deal with that same
repercussion like because Marvel has a
million things that we're comparing it
to when Netflix didn't really do that
was the only nerd stuff they really
really had otherwise I was watching like
I don't even know what I was watching on
Netflix at the time something stupid I'm
sure uh so I'm like it we didn't really
have to compare it to anything and
Jessica Jones like season one and
Daredevil season one were just so
incredible I I was like I don't can we
compare the worst of each and see like
what's the lowest and see how they
compare what was worse secret Invasion
or Iron Fist oh oh [__] oh my God I
would say Iron Fist Iron Fist was more
disappointing than aggravating um
because secret Novation was bad but at
least had a couple Great Moments in
there I see you're lucky Iron Fist was
so long ago that it's hard for me to
like cuz I put it in the back back of my
head but I remember being aggravated
during Secret Invasion I I was
aggravated I was
aggravated [__] yeah I'll go your way
but it's only because I remember that
was a bad that was a bad one why would
you give those two why would you put
those two against each other because
they were respectably the worst of those
of those runs I just think like at the
very at the end of the day at the end of
the day secret invion had Samuel Jackson
Olivia Coleman Don
Che they're just a delight yeah I love
the they are just a delight to watch
actors were great everything else wanted
to choke okay got it they killed Maria
Hill oh my God killed her how could oh
my God and then I was like oh I love
this first episode because she's not
dead never came back saw her funeral and
I went oh so she is dead I was said we
just killed her for no reason and
immediately okay I'm sorry what was what
was worse Maria Hill getting uh getting
killed in the first episode or the
conversation with her mother in The Next
Episode I think that was more cringey I
mean that was Terri I was also like what
you I was so confused with her mom the
entire conversation I was like yeah your
daughter was doing this was the least
craziest thing your daughter did
honestly was going up against this
horrible man but it was that
conversation was so weird I was like we
don't know who you are this is weird
I've never seen you oh God if you're
looking to ring in the New Year by
ringing in a new you revamping your
daily hygiene routine is the best place
to start and geology is here to help
your New Year's resolutions with new
skincare Solutions
geology is a 29 time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognized in
men's health opra daily hype Beast
birdie Esquire and GQ geology's products
use just like a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have been
trusted by dermatologists for decades
geology can help you fight acne reduce
oiless prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging I mean is
it really a new year if you don't age I
don't think so if you don't know where
to start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30se second quiz right now if you
use code new rockstars 100 geology will
give you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body product when you
add it to your trial so 100% off plus an
additional 30% off hope you save some
champagne because this is a deal worth
celebrating click the link in the
description or go to G log. i/ Rockstar
100 get started why would you put those
two up against each other I I we had to
talk I mean it's a difficult
conversation and this I we have to
revisit the worst of these things before
we just say yeah can all be Canon
because like we're talking about 13
episode seasons and we're talking about
like well the Defenders was Eight
Episodes but like there's so much that
happened and it wasn't like Avengers
level conflicts for the most part but uh
things like Kingpin being arrested
because like the issue is in Hawkeye
Kingpin was established as a as an
operative running the tracksuit Mafia as
far back as 2007 but Kingpin was like
kind of a man of the shadows as of 2014
in in the aftermath of the Avengers uh
battle New York so like how big of a of
a Crime Boss was he and when did you
know so that's what I'm saying we got to
let go of the past I think if we're just
gonna I I think it's okay to look back
and I I think anything that encourages
people to go back and watch those
seasons of Daredevil and Jessica Jones
Luke Cage Great I'm in favor of because
there was a lot of amazing television
honestly that that happened on those
shows um and and I don't want people to
think that they're skippable yeah I I
just it's funny because uh my biggest
takeaway from Kingpin after leaving
Netflix and coming into the Disney
Universe is just like oh I assume he
owns everything uh in New York just like
little businesses every shop every
corner because that's what he was that
that's where his game was and that's the
only reason why I'm like oh these Canon
things mean so much now that we're
getting into Echo where it's all
grounded level things now that anytime
we're touching the ground in New York
I'm like who owns this building is it
Kingpin is it a drug Den again um and
that's all I show the Le and also do you
think they're bringing in yeah show show
show me the
least do you think they're bringing in
the fact that like do you remember the
episode of Daredevil where Kingpin sent
with the woman um I think it was Madam
gal went and blew up every part of the
city oh yeah that's right he she
interrupted his date and then there was
like bombs going off everywhere and he
was like Vanessa don't you like this and
Vanessa said oo yeah and I went what oy
yes oy bomb the city for me I said girl
go back to your weird paintings but I
was with your little gun in your purse
what are you GNA he survives a bullet
regardless this is worse this is worse
than my rant about Peppa and uh of ptra
but I yeah is that coming over like I
mean it's I just want to know how strong
he is in money not just as in strength I
want to
know what he owns here's what I think
they're going to kind of like peac meal
certain things from the Netflix
backstory right I think everything with
Wilson fist back backstory clubbing his
dad with the hammer for the campaign
signs keep that intact that was awesome
we staring at the wall and the wall
paint is chipping awesome everything
with like Matt Murdoch getting the
chemical spill in his eyes great
everything was stick great yeah now when
he goes to college we could leave out
the Electra naos stuff when he's like a
law student I don't need that to be to
come up but you also don't need to talk
about it you don't need to bring up when
he was in law school just focus on him
being a lawyer right now in the cases
he's taking right now the stick one is
actually a good observation I forgot
completely about stick and also in like
a weird comic book run stick tot
blade and I'm always like oh cool now
you can just rope stick into literally
anyone else in the MCU you can be like
oh yeah he trained other people too um
with his mean Behavior oh I forgot about
stick he'll probably be brought over
well in the second half of this episode
we're gonna touch on some specific
things that actually happened I think
that many of you might have forgotten
about in that Netflix continuity so
we're going to have to talk about those
first couple announcements very big week
for new rockstars because we have the
episodes of Ekko dropping all on Tuesday
and new rockstars will be breaking down
those episodes one day at a time every
single one of those breakdowns is going
to be hosted by Jessica Clemens Jessica
I'm so excited to see what you see and
to hear your explanations of what
happens on this show what can we look
forward to everything I am breaking down
every corner of this show everything the
research they did into this role the how
they're blowing out this character all
the interviews that I've been watching
with the director what they want to
accomplish and I am talking about all of
it and I'm so excited because eeko was
amazing and this is our first Marvel
Spotlight so we need to treat it as such
I will be watching and you know what I
don't want any of you people thinking
that because I didn't break down this
show that I'm not interested in it no go
f yourself I'm super excited to watch
this show I'm very excited for it but
you know what it's dropping on Jessica's
birthday and we got screeners for it
when I was out on fraternity leave and I
had to leave a little bit earlier
because my son arrived early and you
know Jessica was able to jump on it
while I was gone and I want to watch
your breakdown so don't don't think that
not into this show I am excited for the
show everything with the Marvel Studios
in front of it whether it's Spotlight or
whatever I'm going to watch it I'm
obviously a Marvel junkie I was like I
want to do eeko because I read ekko's
comics and she's badass and why wouldn't
I want to talk about a badass woman in
the MCU now another announcement before
you get those Echo breakdowns tomorrow
Monday January 8th will be the first
episode of our X-Men rewatch series we
are going back through all 13 of the fox
X-Men films and we are doing in-depth
Easter egg breakdowns of each of them
starting with X-Men 2000 the first movie
that brought Kevin feige into Marvel
film making it's an incredibly important
film pieces of this are going to be
coming back in Deadpool 3 and that's why
we're doing this Deadpool 3 is bringing
back pieces from the fox X-Men
continuity and you're going to need a
proper rewatch series to race yourself
for that and Jessica while I was working
on this I was remembering when you and I
hosted a big question episode of going
back through all those movies to figure
out which are worth watching and which
you can skip which are like important
which which ones are worth watching Eric
all of
them especially dark Phoenix and new mut
I bet most of the people watching this
video right now I bet I bet we're not
alive before the first two X-Men moves I
I bet you guys were watching all the
other X-Men's when you were in
elementary school or middle school it's
so nostalgic to go back as an adult and
look through it and be like oh this
scene that I thought was really cool
actually is not that
cool yep well can I tell you my theory
for like why people are so like quick to
[__] on the fox X-Men movies like cuz
you know I've gotten some heat recently
for saying like 2016 Deadpool 2017 Logan
and 2014 Days of Future Past are better
than most of the MCU films and people
like came after me they're like what are
you talking about and I'm like dude
remember watching the infinity Saga
before infinity War an end game happened
yeah phase three rocked phase two was
uneven phase one
had some great films some we weren't
really sure where this universe was
going so like yeah the best of the MCU
is better than the best of the fox X-Men
series and the worst of the MCU is
better than the worst of the fox X-Men
series but a few of those films are
better than like I don't know 80% of the
MCU I don't understand who is yelling
about this unless they're immediately
hearing you and saying oh he said it's
better than all of the MCU and it's like
no I said these four films are just like
masterpieces and they were they were
amazing I just think people think that
the infinity Saga was like all part of
one movie after end and they forget like
the infinity Saga ended on such a high
that it gave Rose tinted glasses for
everything that came before it which is
I think just a testament to how well
Kevin fogy ended up putting this
universe together but that doesn't clear
all wounds from Thor of the Dark World
from the 2008 Hulk movie from the
Ant-Man movies and I think it's not so
much Disney the MCU movies it's just
saying that like Deadpool was that good
Days of Future Past was that good Logan
was that good and they are better than
most of what Marvel Studios came out and
that's not a dis against Marvel Studios
it's just saying that those movies are
that good those movies that's why you
need to rewatch the series that's
exciting though uh have fun re-watching
all the X-Men and going through it the
first one came out when I was like aging
myself when I was in kindergarten and I
remember I watched it and was like this
is the best thing I've ever seen in my
entire life not only did I buy it it was
like one of the first DVDs that I ever
bought in in like 2001 now okay also be
sure to check out nerd r. shop where you
can always grab the latest and greatest
in new rockstars Gear with Echo around
the corner check out our who's the
monster Kingpin shirt that looks so cool
you can support this Channel and check
out our great merch options over at nerd
riot. shop and don't forget to subscribe
to all three channels of the N rockars
Network new rockstars the Deep dive in
the breakroom so just to remind everyone
of everything that came out in the uh
Netflix Marvel lineup we had Daredevil
and there were three seasons of
Daredevil there was The Punisher series
multiple seasons of Punisher Jessica
Jones had multiple Seasons Luke k and
multiple Seasons we had Iron Fist and we
had a teamup series that was Eight
Episodes called Defenders you mentioned
all the explosions that happened in
Daredevil season one where Wilson Fisk
was part of this turf war with the
Russian gangs and blowing and and Madame
gal was involved with that sending human
bombs you know suicide bombers into
these different targets um Daredevil
season 3 had Bullseye like impersonating
Matt Murdoch in some areas it ended with
uh Wilson fist getting arrested and he
had already been incarcerated from the
end of season one into season two so is
Wilson fisk's incarceration going to
come up in uh J born again and Ekko is
that part of it and then we've left out
kilgrave David Tenant who if from from
Jessica Jones Jessica Jones is so good
and if they bring in Jessica Jones to be
canon in the way that they're saying
Daredevil was David Tenant as kilgrave
shoots to the top of the list of best
most terrifying villains in the Marvel
Universe horrible man it's always the
sweetest best actor playing the worst
human like I'm sure mad Mickelson is
probably a very nice man but I don't
think so because I know his character
and he eats people he eats people that's
a monster that's a horrible person we
all you like universally hate this
person there's so much that happens uh
in all these shows with other characters
coming in not all of them are
apocalyptic events they do reference the
events of the 2012 Avengers they don't
do any that's the thing none of these
shows do anything to contradict what
happened in the MCU history and I think
that's why Brad Windom is saying yeah
they can be part of it but to make them
Cannon you're setting up an expectation
to people who love those shows that
you're going to be bringing back a lot
of elements because a lot of like
open-ended things were were left in
place I mean season three of
Daredevil gets arrested yeah and again
like you said Bullseye literally gets
turned into a bionic man but we don't it
just goes away it just never comes back
I those things are so minor that I don't
think it will hurt not to be addressed
because again it's still you take those
big things we're taking those big things
where keeping those in line but these
smaller things maybe we can address
later or they come up organically but I
don't think it's going to hurt too much
to not address it but the Fisk being in
prison I bet will just be a line that
was like I've been to prison they're
just G to be vague about it I think
that's what it is they're going to be
all these characters will not maybe not
all of them but they'll be vague and
they'll be like yeah using my corruption
using my connections I was able to get
out of I bought off it's just a matter
of killing a few judges and buying off
the rest like that's what it's
it's going to be [__] like that and then
Jessica Jones is going to be like yeah I
went on sabatical for a bit from working
some detective case files and I'm back
that will piss me off if it's that I
don't know why but it would it's gonna
be that but that would make me mad
Kingpin talking about his prison thing
I'm like yeah I guess that makes sense
you're just like I can pay off people
Jessica Jones being like I went on
vacation I'm like you went on vacation
the person that's haunted by every
nightmare of crime in the life you went
on vacation [__] it it's hard to
draw the line like I I think it's it's
okay to say Daredevil is Canon but
Defenders and Matt Murdoch was in
Defenders and Defenders was crazy
Defenders was in Crazy the vendors was
black Sky the hand a big hole in New
York City that's a lot it's a lot of
like M that you're gonna have to just
like sift through if if you are strict
by it so that's why I say if if you're
excited by this news and I think
ultimately it is a good thing to
encourage people to go by watch just
don't treat those shows as goel and and
don't treat anything as gospel just like
appreciate what you have right now and
just like just be happy that more people
are going to go back and watch these
shows now and we can all just move
forward from there I mean we have to do
the math right now considering every
single episode of every single season of
those shows we are talking about
potentially double or maybe even triple
the number of minutes screen time
minutes that have been in Marvel Studios
Phase 1 two three and four films oh yeah
and even TV shows because the TV shows
on Marvel uh Disney Plus have just been
like six episodes and they're all 35
minutes each yeah you know it gives you
more time to also actually tell the full
story to give like to like round it all
out all side characters everything it's
pacing is good its pacing was great
can't wait for those 18 episodes
honestly born again yeah I just like I
think I might be even more excited by
the idea of Jessica Jones coming into
the MCU if only if it just gets as caran
Moss as as Hogarth
do we need loot cage I think we do I I
like want him in and it's it's it sucks
because it's like I which they talked
about this with Ekko the director was
like she's not going to be the Eko that
you guys see in the comics because that
one's kind of lame um and I was like she
said that not my word she said that
she's like those she's a she's a mimic
she's like Taskmaster she's like
Bullseye so it's like she's going to be
different in the series and I feel like
if you put Luke Cage in you're putting
another very strong super soldier person
in but I love Luke Cage and I want him
in all right well we will see how much
gets established we probably won't learn
too much this week but I think we'll get
some references to the to the past of
the Netflix uh continuity it's an
exciting time it is an exciting time and
it's going to be a great year here on
new rock stars uh Jess I can't wait to
talk to you on the other side of Ekko
and to watch all of your breakdowns this
week be sure to subscribe to the break
room though because the immediate
reactions to the first couple episodes
of Ekko are going to be on the break
room Channel and then there will be like
a lingering questions episode in the
middle of the week and I believe at the
end of the week will be like uh the
break rooms finale SL full season
reaction so be sure to subscribe to that
subscribe to new rock stars follow
Jessica Lulu Clemens you can follow me
at eav Vos and uh we'll see you next
week bye Jess bye
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]